leaving just enough open to
interpretation can make a movie immortal
ensuring that fans will be left debating
the meaning of their favourites for
years to come
in that vein we've assembled an
assortment of movies that have left
audiences puzzle here are a few of the
most confusing plot twists explained I
missed out on the whole thing to be
honestly I was confused by it I'm very
confused by though I was very confused
by the whole thing to be if I'm being
honest who's who in Lost Highway in
1997's Lost Highway we meet Fred Madison
a jazz musician accused of murdering his
wife Renee Fred goes to jail but the
next morning the guards discover that
Fred's place has been taken by Pete
Dayton a car mechanic with mild amnesia
Pete is soon entangled with Alice
Wakefield a woman who looks identical to
the murdered Renee the movie continually
questions who's who all while a
mysterious man follows them both
videotaping the confusing carnage that
ensues the obsessive display of
infidelity characters watching and being
watched and grisly murders might all
seem familiar to anyone who watched the
OJ Simpson trial in 1995 nearly 10 years
after lost highways release director
David Lynch would elaborate on the
connection between the movie and the
Simpson trial in his book catching the
big fish Lynch wrote I wondered how if a
person did these deeds he could go on
living and we found this great
psychology term psychogenic fugue
describing an event where the mind
tricks itself to escape some horror Fred
Madison is a man who murdered his wife
and invented an entire alternate life
story to escape his own guilt it's
fitting then that the movie ends with a
high-speed car chase in which Fred feels
out of control at least it wasn't on the
405 highway like OJ Vertigo's
look-alikes 40 years before David Lynch
confounded audiences with lost highways
pair of look-alike characters played by
the same actress Alfred Hitchcock pulled
a similar trick in vertigo the film
introduces us to Scottie a private
investigator who has retired from police
work due to his struggles with well
vertigo his old friend Gavin hire
Scottie to trail his wife Madeleine
because he fears she's possessed by the
spirit of her great-grandmother
Madeleine is drawn to the mission where
her great-grandmother died and rushes up
the bell tower
Scottie's vertigo prevents him from
following and he watches in horror as
she falls to her death
he's so shaken that he's committed to an
institution upon release he meets a
woman named Judy who looks
eerily like Madeline the to begin an
unhealthy relationship biscotti remakes
Judy to look like Madeline you're
looking for the suit that she wore from
me you want me to be dressed like her
Judy I just want to do it up tonight a
flashback reveals the twist that the
Madeline Scottie knew was always Judy
who Gavin hired in an elaborate plot to
get rid of his wife all of the
supernatural elements of the story were
concocted to confuse Scottie whose
vertigo was guaranteed to leave him a
helpless witness to the fake fatality
parental revelations after ray was
introduced in the force awakens with beg
questions about the identity of her
long-lost parents the last Jedi had her
confront the truth in a shocking twist
for viewers that were expecting some
variation of Luke Skywalker's own
twisted family tree it turns out that
her parents were nobody important while
some saw this twist as a cop-out
director Rian Johnson had his reasons
thematic parallels are an essential part
of the Star Wars formula as George Lucas
likes to say yes like portraits so that
they run kind of rhymes with class point
on an episode of Empire's film podcast
Johnson explained that he didn't just
write that moment to contrast the famous
scene in Empire Strikes Back it's
actually the most dramatic and difficult
thing for Ray to reckon with instead of
being given a tailored role in the story
like so many heroes before her she gets
told that her place isn't where she's
been looking for it hardest thing to
hear is nope this is not gonna define
you in fact this is going to kylo is
gonna use this to try and undercut your
confidence so that you'll feel you have
to lean on him for your identity it's
now in her hands to find her own
identity it's purposeful and it's an
intentional change in the familiar
patterns found in all previous Star Wars
films psycho-killer
American Psycho is designed to leave
audiences wondering how much of what
they've seen is actually real as the
film reaches its climax in an
over-the-top killing spree riddled with
explosions and swooping police
helicopters it becomes clear that
Patrick Bateman may not be an entirely
reliable narrator the morning after the
climactic chaos Bateman returns to the
apartment where he'd been executing
people for weeks ready to clean up the
evidence of his misdeeds he's disturbed
to find the place empty and freshly
painted you saw the ad and the time
No yeah I mean yeah in the times there
was no Adam the times what does this
scene represent for the plot according
to screenwriter Guinevere Turner he did
do all this stuff and he still cannot
stand out he stuck because Batemans
crimes are so unremarkable in the film's
viciously heightened universe of Wall
Street capitalism that all attention
even punishment will elude him forever
not Davis
I'm Patrick Bateman twisted timelines as
the Fast & Furious franchise has
branched out into ambitious new plot
threads it's quickly revealed itself as
a labyrinth of nonlinear narrative that
must be explored in the words of the
immortal Dominic Toretto quarter-mile at
a time in the series third film 2006 is
Tokyo Drift newcomer Shawn Boswell is
taken under the wing of Han a racer who
teaches him the power of drifting
unfortunately Han is tragically killed
during a race prompting Toretto to
appear and declare himself an old friend
of Hans in the final scene now here's
where the twist comes in 2009 saw the
release of the series fourth film Fast &
Furious which reunited the original cast
and han on says he's off to Tokyo
leading the audience to believe that the
fourth film takes place concurrently
with the third but no Hans back again in
a more significant role in Fast Five and
sticks around through fast and furious 6
the story finally catches up to Hans
death in a post-credits scene at the end
of the sixth movie which reveals that
Deckard Shaw the villain of Furious 7
was actually responsible for the
accident in Tokyo Drift so the series
chronology means that Tokyo Drift
actually happens in between the sixth
and seventh movie although don't expect
the series to get any simpler just
because the timeline finally matches up
series writer Chris Morgan has recently
speculated that Han could come back yet
again and why not
after all han is family and you don't
just a dream right despite the
popularity of The Nightmare on Elm
Street franchise director Wes Craven
never envisioned the series living
beyond one film executive producer
Robert Shaye disagreed hoping to leave
the door open for a follow-up and the
compromise they reached resulted in a
fairly baffling finale for the original
movie even though Nancy vanquished
Freddy earlier in the film the ending
scene seems to imply his return
when she's trapped in a convertible
bearing Krueger's trademark red and
green stripes what does it all mean when
Nancy reappears in a Nightmare on Elm
Street three dream warriors she mentions
that Krueger got rid of her friends and
her mother we can assume then that Nancy
undoing the murders in her defeat of
Krueger was a dream in itself in the
documentary never sleep again Robert
Englund
the actor who plays Freddy Krueger
proposes his own theory that the film is
a precognitive nightmare everything in
it will happen but it hasn't really
happened she's just dreamt that it's
going to happen and she's trying to warn
everybody and then it begins at the
other than Allah Thunder Andy
[Music]